whatever your opinion of him John
Stewart has been a major cultural and
political commentator for the past 16
years he liked to take down the powerful
at least when his head wasn't shoved up
Uncle Sam's ass here the top five ways
Stewart was full of [ __ ] number five
Stewart's views on science John wasn't
afraid to go after pseudoscience
peddling morons
even the anti-vaccine science denying
affluent California liberals but see
it's a laugh line because only stupid
poor conservatives deny science am i
right amen by the way where might these
other wise enlightened liberals have
gotten such an idea really overwhelming
science linking those autism rates to
the thimerosal that wasn't the vaccine I
appreciate you getting the word out and
I know parents of kids with autism truly
appreciate it I know that it's a very
difficult than thing for them to be
dealing with so I'll bet they do John
I'll bet they do at number 4 is
Stewart's love of taxes he was quick to
call a [ __ ] political rhetoric you
managed to talk about a tax hike as a
spending reduction can we afford that
and the royalty checks you're gonna have
to send the George Orwell but he mainly
just wanted to help our poor friends in
Washington with their finances bring the
highest marginal tax rate back to what
it was in the 1990s I go again then you
pay and they're 9 it's not true of
course the feds are taking in record tax
revenues and have doubled spending since
the 90s so giving them more money to get
better results might be like upgrading
from a $5 to a $10 hooker to get a
better STD but what if we put other
bureaucrats in charge of making sure the
government doesn't waste a ton of money
the people holding the conference that
wasted a ton of government money are the
people in charge of making sure the
government doesn't waste a ton of money
all right then coming in at number three
is Stewart's view on how other people
treat their own bodies I don't
understand the idea of staying with a
market-based solution for a problem
where people can't be smart consumers
there create a single-payer system that
doesn't sound very pro-choice if only we
had a government-run system for
comparison like
the Department Veterans Affairs okay so
we do but it would be pretty ironic if
Stuart had bashed it repeatedly for the
backlogs and the obscenely long wait
times for appointments with the backlogs
the obscenely long wait times for
appointments
yikes but as long as we raise taxes John
is confident vets will get good care
soon just that's the president Harry
Truman who said in 1945 this is true
quote the Veterans Administration will
be modernized as soon as possible but I
can't do it immediately
which brings us to number two Stu knows
bad things happen when we empower a
corrupt bureaucracy to pick winners and
losers these corporations lobby to get
all kinds of arcane things put into the
regulation that makes it harder for
these small businesses they don't want
to deregulate in some measure because
then they lose their funding so he must
be stunned now at the conflation of
government obstruction in the American
Dream I'm stunned now at the conflation
of unobstructed capitalism and the
American Dreams is the dreaded
capitalism watch out or it might give
you an iPhone maybe John would rather
have Jeb Bush tell him he needs a
blackberry in a wider catheter which
brings us to our number one wage on
store was full of [ __ ] his benevolent
view of big brother when it comes to
Politburo [ __ ] that impacts his
audience stew has killed it
the president is not getting warrants
because he's got a job to do to protect
us he's like a figure that makes sure no
harm comes to us like a paternalistic
girl I like a big brother if you would
this soda is twice as illegal
as this much weed now let's see that
consistent outrage at other stupid rags
that don't affect elite urbanites
but can force the most vulnerable
members of society into tragic run-ins
with the law some politician also had to
direct the police to say hey we want you
arresting people for selling a loose
cigarette what are you talking about
honestly Eric garner could have been out
there with mixtapes or a squeegee or a
snow cone and the same kind of could
have happened there it is yes the same
kind of [ __ ] could have happened because
of the stupid regulation of all of those
things that you just mentioned does
anybody see a pattern here but at his
best stored saw through the partisan
hysterics magnified by media height and
sought his own truth which is more than
we can say for most Talking Heads your
partisan what'd he call it hax so thanks
for that John now if you'll just cut out
the rest of this [ __ ] Jah why are you
such an [ __ ]